cela dit le clou de la soirée était le
combat des lourds-légers titre de
champion de france en jeu opposant le
tenant du titre
christophe dettinger 26 ans de massy
amérique roberge et 31 ans de rouen 10
reprises de trois minutes des temps j'ai
26 ans le plus grand des deux à m 92
pour 91 kg roberge et 1 m 86 dettinger
compte huit combats 8 victoires dont 4
avant la limite
roberge et 25 combats 19 victoires pour
6 défaites
bref un combat de puncheur dettinger
procèdent par des direct puissant et
tire profit de son allonge supérieure
roberge et souvent sur le reculoir à la
7e reprise le rouennais est blessé au
cuir chevelu ce qui n'arrange pas ses
affaires
christophe dettinger termine le match en
trombe
le rouennais a du mal à rester debout
c'est la victoire de dj qui défendait
son titre pour la première fois les
ambitions c'est le gars de monty
d'apprendre mon métier et d'aller plus
loin
c'est possible j'appelle à l'europe
neuvième victoire en neuf matches le
massicois est peut-être la prochaine
vedette française de la boxe pro
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]